looks like some big changes are coming
to one of the new Witcher games that CD
projekt announced last October on March
20th the company revealed that the new
Witcher game in development at the
Molasses Flood in Boston codenamed
project Sirius underwent an evaluation
of its scope and Commercial potential
against the original concept based on
the evaluation cdproject decided to take
an impairment allowance of close to 10
million dollars video game business
reporter game over 30 said that CD
projekt's move here suggest a complete
scrapping of the existing version of
project Sirius CD projek's statement
went on to say that the company will now
work on formatting a new framework for
this project a spokesperson for CD
projekt told Gamespot quote our current
focus is ensuring that project series is
aligned with the strategy of the CV
project group at this point in time we
are neither providing insight into the
evaluation of the products nor the
potential future Frameworks thereof back
when the game was announced project
build it as an Innovative Take On The
Witcher series aimed at veterans and
newcomers alike it was in pre-production
as of October 2022 and had more than 60
people working on it other games that
were announced back then included a new
Trilogy of Mainline Witcher games from
CD projekt Red itself as well as a third
party Witcher game codenamed Canis
Majoris whenever I hear that a game
Studio a movie studio or even a music
artist has decided to scrap a project
and start over it makes me wish I was a
fly on the wall I want to know why they
made that decision and what the original
product looked like maybe one day I'll
get the answers I'm looking for but
until then let's talk about another game
that might see some changes before
release just not the completely starting
overcon talking about Diablo 4 The
Game's Early Access beta has concluded
and a lot of people took part how many
well we now know that it's more than one
million blizzard said on Twitter that
more than one million people reached at
least level 20 which Grant them a
special bonus everyone who hits level 20
of the 25 in the beta gets the beta wolf
pack item that includes a cute little
wolf cub as announced previously all
progress from The Early Access beta
carries forward into this week's open
Beta so anyone who didn't reach level 20
already can keep pushing ahead to earn
the item but it's important to know that
progress will not carry over to the full
release in June just Early Access to
open Beta the only thing that's carrying
forward to June is the beta wolf pack if
you unlock it but this is good news for
me because I kept jumping between three
characters and only got to level 15 with
one of them so definitely jumping into
the open Beta to grab that wolf cub hit
the comments and let me know if you
unlock the wolf pack and if you've
cleared your schedule for this weekend's
open Beta period see you tomorrow
foreign